there's no specimen of human being that
is more privileged than the English
white woman and when I used to see how
much they would complain about the
oppression they experienced and I just
thought to myself you definitely still
have more rights than somebody like my
father who's got a bit of an accent and
he's definitely Muslim and you
definitely have more of a privilege than
the Caribbean guys or the Nigerian guys
or the Muslim guys when you go to the
airport but because people are so almost
dying to be a victim they would complain
about such small things I remember like
being in schools and the teachers would
complain like oh God the music is too
many male answers that's inequality and
I just thought you don't know what
suffering is you haven't experienced it
but you want to because it gives you
meaning and purpose I felt and this is
probably going to sound bad but I felt
like it was the most privileged members
of society complaining about being
oppressed when they haven't seen true
oppression